and we hit shift enter boom uh and the reason why it's showing four is the answer is because it's doing the last unit test so if we do that again we get boom uh that doesn't look right Welcome to ADSP, the podcast episode 60 recorded on January 8th, 2022. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host Bryce, we talk about BQNs after and construct a Twitter poll to settle the debate, are parentheses necessary? Wait, where are you? Is that a Zoom background? background no we're in google meet or is it a is it you're not actually you're not actually in this like cafe that appears behind you right nope i can't believe you can't even tell man i i could tell hey there's. There's snow. I want to have a snowball fight. And I figured there must be some way, like in New York City, there must be some organization for like adults that want to have snowball fights.
然后我们按下 shift enter，轰，呃，它显示 4 作为答案的原因是它正在运行最后一个单元测试，所以如果我们再做一次，我们得到轰，呃，看起来不太对。欢迎来到第 60 期 ADSP 播客，录制于 2022 年 1 月 8 日。我是康纳，今天我和我的联合主持人布莱斯一起讨论 BQN 的后序操作，并建立了一个推特投票来解决这个争论：括号是必要的吗？等等，你在哪？那是 Zoom 背景吗？背景，没有，我们在谷歌会议里，或者它是，你是，你实际上，你实际上不在这个出现在你身后的咖啡馆里，对吧？不，我简直不敢相信你甚至看不出来，伙计，我，我看得出来。嘿，有，有雪。我想打雪仗。我想一定有什么办法，比如在纽约市，一定有一些组织是给那些想打雪仗的成年人准备的。
But I mean, obviously probably not practical with COVID. No, maybe it is practical with COVID because like it's an outdoor activity. Anyways, if there's anybody in New York City who wants to have a snowball fight with me, please let me know. I'd love to have a snowball fight. No, like no ice in the snow though. Like that's none of that nonsense. You're a full grown adult asking to have a snowball fight with your adult friends. That is correct. I, not even with my adult, like not even with your adult friends. That is correct. Not even with my adult, like not even with like specific friends. I'm just like, I'm a grown adult announcing on my podcast to the internet that I'd like to have a snowball fight. This actually reminds me of a story. So this episode is going to be our 2021 retro talking about the highlights and a couple
但我的意思是，显然在新冠疫情期间可能不太现实。不，也许在新冠疫情期间是现实的，因为这是一种户外活动。总之，如果纽约市有谁想跟我打雪仗，请告诉我。我很想打雪仗。不，雪里不要有冰。那种胡闹可不行。你是一个成年人，却要求和你的成年朋友打雪仗。没错。我甚至不是和我的成年，甚至不是和你的成年朋友。没错。甚至不是和我的成年，甚至不是和像特定的朋友。我只是，我是一个成年人，在我的播客上向互联网宣布我想打雪仗。这实际上让我想起了一个故事。所以这一集将是我们的 2021 年回顾，讨论亮点和一些
other things. Before we get to that though, I will tell the story of when I lived in China in 2012, which we talked about all the way back. You know how many years ago 2012 was? Yeah, we're old men now. But during Christmas time, or maybe it was January of 2013, it snowed in Hangzhou, the city I was living in, and the locals went like crazy. I was at this lake called West Lake, Shihu,
其他事情。不过，在我们讨论那个之前，我要讲一个故事，关于我 2012 年在中国居住时的经历，我们很久以前就谈过这个。你知道 2012 年是多少年前吗？是的，我们现在是老头子了。但在圣诞节期间，或者可能是 2013 年 1 月，我居住的城市杭州下雪了，当地人简直快疯了。我当时在西湖这个湖，
and I guess it doesn't snow there very often, and it snowed like a few inches so that you could have a snowball fight, and there ended up being... I was young at the time, and so I ended up sort of like very playfully throwing a couple snowballs at like these kids that were playing in this little grassy area that, you know, had a bunch of snow. And then five minutes later, I, it was like this 20, 30 person, you know, snowball fight. Half of them were kids and like half of them were like grown adults.
我想那里不常下雪，雪下了几英寸，所以你可以打雪仗，结果发现……我当时很年轻，所以最后我有点像，非常顽皮地向在那个长满了雪的小草地上玩耍的孩子们扔了几个雪球。然后五分钟后，我，这就像是一个 20、30 人的，你知道的，打雪仗。他们有一半是孩子，还有一半是成年人。
Some, some of them were bringing and like half of them were like, uh, grown adults. Some, some of them were bringing their umbrellas. Um, why you have an umbrella while it's snowing is not entirely clear, but many folks had umbrellas and it was, uh, is, uh, it was one of the most wonderful memories of my life. I was there with a friend, Antonio, who still lives in China. And, um, yeah yeah the snowball fight of christmas 2012 it was just like the coolest craziest and yeah anyways snowball fights are fun that sounds that sounds lovely that sounds lovely so so so what's with the what's with the google meet background are you just like embarrassed by your you know closet that i've been teasing you about? Nope, nope.
有些，有些人带了，还有一半是，呃，成年人。有些，有些人带了雨伞。呃，下雪的时候你为什么要带雨伞，这一点并不十分清楚，但许多人都带了雨伞，而且，这是，呃，这是我一生中最美好的回忆之一。我和朋友安东尼奥在那里，他现在仍然住在中国。而且，嗯，是的，是的，2012 年圣诞节的打雪仗，就像是最酷、最疯狂的，并且，是的，无论如何打雪仗很有趣，听起来，听起来很可爱，听起来很可爱，所以，所以，所以谷歌会议的背景是怎么回事？你是不是觉得你的，你知道的，我一直在取笑你的那个衣橱很尴尬？不，不。
I'm not even, I'm technically not even in the closet today because I need to screen share. And I just discovered this the other day. I was having a meeting and the person I was with had a little background. I was like, I didn't know Google Meets did that. And it's the best. So I got this little, you even thought I was in a cafe. Connor, if you have the background, I can't judge your interior decorating.
我甚至，今天严格来说我甚至不在衣橱里，因为我需要共享屏幕。我前几天刚发现这个。我当时在开会，和我在一起的人有一个小背景。我说，我不知道谷歌会议有这个功能。这太棒了。所以我弄了这个小东西，你甚至以为我在咖啡馆里。康纳，如果你有这个背景，我就无法评判你的室内装饰了。
All right, fair enough. You like the flowers in the background of mine? Yeah, I took out the vase, I put some flowers in, yeah. It's feeling floral today. No, no, no, no, no, no, no. It's okay. You can have your Google Meet background.
好吧，挺公平的。你喜欢我背景里的花吗？是的，我拿掉了花瓶，放了一些花，是的。今天感觉很有花卉气息。不，不，不，不，不，不，不。没关系。你可以用你的谷歌会议背景。
I don't want to ruin your fun. I'll still find ways to make fun of your interior decorating. Literally, I turn it off and it's just white walls in the background. White walls and a white chair. White walls, white chair, yeah. All right. Before we get – well, actually, how's it going, man? We haven't chatted in a few weeks.
我不想破坏你的乐趣。我还是会找到方法来取笑你的室内装饰。真的，我把它关掉，背景就只有白墙。白墙和一把白椅子。白墙，白椅子，嗯。好了。在我们开始——好吧，事实上，最近怎么样，伙计？我们已经有几周没聊天了。
Happy New Year. Happy New Year. actually, how's it going, man? We haven't chatted in a few weeks. Happy New Year. Happy New Year. Yeah. How's your New Year going? So far, so good. January 8th. We're a week in, 100K down, and it's going pretty good so far. How's your New Year going?
新年快乐。新年快乐。事实上，最近怎么样，伙计？我们已经有几周没聊天了。新年快乐。新年快乐。是的。你的新年过得怎么样？目前为止，一切都好。1 月 8 日。我们已经过了一周，10 万粉丝达成，目前进展相当顺利。你的新年过得怎么样？
It's pretty good. Pretty good. Yeah. All right. So let's do this retrospective wait wait wait so I've got a list of things I actually have notes it's like the first time because we haven't spoken in so
挺好的。挺好的。是的。好的。那我们来做这个回顾，等等，等等，所以，我有一个清单，我实际上有笔记，这就像是第一次，因为我们已经很久没说话了，
long that there's all these little things that I wanted to bring up the first thing most importantly and this is sort of if we've got any new listeners today you're going to be prepared to be confused because we're going to be referencing an old episode and not giving a ton of context. Let me do a screen share, a window, and we shall choose this one.
有这么多小事情我想提出来，第一件事，也是最重要的一件事，如果你今天有任何新听众，你要做好感到困惑的准备，因为我们要引用一个旧的节目，却没有提供太多的上下文。让我做一个屏幕共享，一个窗口，我们选择这个。
Do you remember the BQN solution? And I promise, listeners, we did get a couple complaints on the Twitter about how all the episodes have been awesome. They love the content, but like maybe don't live code, especially in a language that is just Unicode symbols. I think in the future, we're going to save the live coding for like YouTube episodes, which, which are coming listener.
你还记得 BQN 的解决方案吗？我向听众保证，我们在推特上确实收到了一些投诉，关于所有的节目都非常棒，他们喜欢这些内容，但也许不要进行实时编码，特别是在一个只有统一码符号的语言中。我想在未来，我们要把实时编码留给像 YouTube 节目这样的地方，听众们，这些节目就要来了。
They are coming. Sure. After the Balkan tour, 2023. Um, yes. But, uh,
它们就要来了。当然。2021 年巴尔干巡演之后。嗯，是的。但是，呃，
so we, we, we've, we've heard you loud and clear. It was, I think, one individual. I don't remember the name, but someone did. I think that one individual probably spoke for many others. Yes. And I think even we even self-reflected in the part two of that live coding being like, this is probably not. Nobody's going to be able to follow this up.
所以我们，我们，我们听到了你们响亮而清晰的声音。我想是一个个人。我不记得名字了，但有人这么做了。我认为那个个人可能代表了许多其他人。是的。而且我想甚至我们在那场实时编码的第二部分中也进行了自我反思，觉得这可能不是。没有人能跟上这个。
Yeah, this is probably not the best content. But the important thing, Connor, is that we had fun. Because at the end of the day, the key thing here is for us to have fun. And if other people happen to have fun, that's fine too. Is that the most important thing? I'm not sure. But yes, having fun is important. Anyways, I will link to the part one and part two of our live coding where we had a very simple problem
是的，这可能不是最好的内容。但重要的是，康纳，我们玩得很开心。因为归根结底，这里的关键是我们要玩得开心。如果其他人也恰好玩得开心，那也很好。这是最重要的事情吗？我不确定。但是，是的，玩得开心很重要。无论如何，我会链接到我们实时编码的第一部分和第二部分，在那里我们有一个非常简单的问题，
that was called target indices. You're given a list of numbers such as one, two, five, two, three, and then you're also given a target value, which in the first example is two. And the problem asks you basically to return a list of indices that correspond to where the target value would show up in the sorted list. So 1, 2, 5, 2, 3. Sorted would be 1, 2, 2, 3, 5. And because we're doing zero indexing, the target value 2 shows up in index 1 and index 2. We're not going to rehash the whole problem solving. We did it once in C++.
叫做目标索引。给你一个数字列表，比如 1、2、5、2、3，然后还给你一个目标值，在第一个例子中是 2。该问题基本上要求你返回一个索引列表，这些索引对应于目标值在排序后的列表中出现的位置。所以 1、2、5、2、3。排序后将是 1、2、2、3、5。因为我们使用的是从零开始的索引，所以目标值 2 出现在索引 1 和索引 2 中。我们不会重新梳理整个问题解决过程。我们在 C++ 中做过一次。
We did it once in BQN. And the only thing I want to highlight is in our final solution, we had this beautiful combinator overloaded galore. And even Bryce said the sad thing is, is that he could actually understand this, where you had sort of two binary transforms, and then you were doing a reduction on both of them and then once you had basically the count of your target values and the number of values that was less than that you could create your list of indices and at one point we had this five character expression left plus range composed with right and then what that was basically doing is it was applying iota to the number of values, target values that show up.
我们在 BQN 中做过一次。我唯一想强调的是，在我们的最终解决方案中，我们有这种美丽的组合子重载盛宴。甚至布莱斯也说，可悲的是，他实际上能理解这一点，你有一种二元转换，然后你对这两者都进行归约，一旦你基本上有了目标值的计数和小于该值的数字的数量，你就可以创建你的索引列表，在某个时刻我们有这个五个字符的表达式：左加范围组合右，然后这基本上是做的是，它将 iota 应用于出现的数字、目标值的数量。
So in our case with two, you're going to go basically range two or iota two to get one two. And then you're adding the number of values that are less than it. And I made some, so you don't really need to fully understand what I said, but we have this five-character expression thing. And if you go back to the episode and listen to it, I said, you know, in J, I think actually there's a thing called the dyadic hook, and this is exactly what it's doing. Well, guess what? On episode 17 of Arraycast, my other podcast, I brought this problem up, or not exactly this problem, but it came to in the middle of the podcast that I discovered you can actually do this in BQN. It is a glyph called, if I get this right, before. Actually, it's called after. And if we zoom out a tiny bit and we hit shift enter, boom.
所以在我们以 2 为例的情况下，你基本上会去获取范围 2 或 iota 2 来得到 1 2。然后你加上小于它的值的数量。我做了一些，所以你其实不需要完全理解我所说的，但我们有这个五个字符的表达式。如果你回到那一集去听，我说，你知道，在 J 语言中，我其实认为有一个叫双向钩（dyadic hook）的东西，这正是它在做的事情。好吧，你猜怎么着？在我的另一个播客 Arraycast 的第 17 期中，我提出了这个问题，或者不完全是这个问题，但在播客进行到一半时，我发现你实际上可以在 BQN 中做到这一点。它是一个被称为，如果我没记错的话，before（前）的字形。事实上，它被称为 after（后）。如果我们稍微缩小一点，然后按下 shift enter，轰。
And the reason why it's showing four is the answer is because it's doing the last unit test. So if we do that again, we get boom. That doesn't look right. Is it after? Is it before? Oh, right, right, right, right, right. Is it right? What's going on here?
它显示 4 作为答案的原因是它正在运行最后一个单元测试。所以如果我们再做一次，我们得到轰。看起来不太对。是 after 吗？是 before 吗？哦，对，对，对，对，对，对。是右边吗？这里是怎么回事？
Watching Connor fail in real time is something else. Nope. Nope. All right. You are going to have to liberally edit this. We're going to go to the place where I have the pre-coded solution. We're coming back to BQN. What am I doing wrong here?
实时看着康纳失败是另一番体验。不。不。好吧。你得大刀阔斧地编辑这个。我们要去我有预先编码的解决方案的地方。我们回到 BQN。我这里哪里做错了？
Oh, right, right, right, right. Yes, yes. Because the way it is is that we're doing. So that's actually what I had before. Why isn't this working? Why isn't this working? It is after. It is after.
哦，对，对，对，对，对。是的，是的。因为它的方式是我们在做。所以这实际上是我以前拥有的。为什么这个不工作？为什么这个不工作？它是 after。它是 after。
Oh, God damn. There's one more. There's one more test that I didn't come. I am going to have to make some editorial decisions here. You are going to have to liberally edit this section. I might just leave it all in. Who knows? Because it's somewhat funny.
哦，该死。还有一个。还有一个测试我没有来。我这里得做一些剪辑决定了。你得大刀阔斧地编辑这一段。我可能直接把它们全留下了。谁知道呢？因为这有点搞笑。
But I had it right before. So it's the after glyph. And literally what this does. But I want to note. I want to note. I think we got feedback on the internet that the internet agrees with me that having the parentheses is better than not having the parentheses. That they help clarify what's going on instead of relying implicitly on order of evaluation rules that only like Connor and the two other BQN programmers in the world know. So, actually, I said I would take that poll, and you're saying that the Twitter agreed? I never actually put that poll up there.
但我之前弄对了。所以它是 after 字形。字面意思是这样的。但我想要指出。我想要指出。我想我们在互联网上收到了反馈，互联网同意我的看法，即有括号比没有括号更好。它们有助于澄清发生了什么，而不是隐式地依赖只有康纳和世界上其他两个 BQN 程序员才知道的求值顺序规则。所以，事实上，我说过我会进行那个投票，而你说推特同意了？我其实从来没有把那个投票发上去。
I'm not saying I have quantitative data, but I do have qualitative data based on we got some tweets when we posted the episode. We got some tweets that said posted the episode. We got some tweets. We got some tweets that said, where's the poll? They didn't actually say lean left or right. Fine, fine, fine. Then let's make the poll. Let's make the poll right now. You want to make – okay.
我不是说我有定量数据，但我确实有定性数据，基于我们在发布这一集时收到了一些推文。我们收到了一些推文说发布了这一集。我们收到了一些推文。我们收到了一些推文说，投票在哪？他们实际上并没有说倾向于左边还是右边。好吧，好吧，好吧。那我们来做这个投票。我们现在就做这个投票。你想做——好吧。
We'll make the poll. We'll make the poll right now. So wait. We'll use this final solution. Yep. And you know what's also valid? Huh? We get rid of these parentheses right here.
我们来做这个投票。我们现在就做这个投票。所以等等。我们将使用这个最终的解决方案。是的。你知道什么也是合法的吗？啊？我们去掉这里的这些括号。
And the problem is – actually, no. The problem is I kind of agree that the parentheses help here. No. You do not get to get out of this. Well, no, no, no. Let's pick another one. But let's do the one where it was. Let's just go find the problem because it was in.
问题是——事实上，不。问题是，我有点赞同括号在这里有帮助。不。你休想逃避这个。好吧，不，不，不。我们选另一个。但让我们做那个有的。我们去找那个问题，因为它在。
We can just go to our show notes. Amazing. When were we talking? Oh, my God. You actually put links to my talk in the show notes. Oh, yeah. And I also went and found your slide deck because that. Oh, yeah. So this was. You found the slide deck from my first conference talk ever. This is actually so this is episode 55, the part one of our live coding.
我们可以直接去我们的节目笔记。太棒了。我们当时在聊什么？哦，天哪。你竟然把我的演讲链接放到了节目笔记里。哦，是的。而且我还去找到了你的幻灯片，因为那个。哦，是的。所以这是。你找到了我第一次参加会议演讲的幻灯片。这实际上，所以这是第 55 期，我们实时编码的第一部分。
And you actually said that your first talk was supercomputing. And then I asked was at supercomputing. And then I asked. It couldn't have been. It couldn't have been supercomputing. My first talk was supercomputing and then I asked, was at supercomputing and then I asked, oh, it couldn't have been supercomputing. My first talk, I think if I said that, I misspoke. My first talk was that way. My first talk was not supercomputing. I said it wasn't BoostCon. It was a Linux Foundation collaboration summit a week before BoostCon.
你实际上说过你的第一次演讲是超级计算（supercomputing）。然后我问是在超级计算吗？然后我问。不可能。那不可能是超级计算。我的第一次演讲是超级计算，然后我问，是在超级计算吗？然后我问，哦，那不可能是超级计算。我的第一次演讲，如果我那么说了，我口误了。我的第一次演讲是那样的。我的第一次演讲不是超级计算。我说不是 BoostCon。那是 BoostCon 前一周的一个 Linux 基金会协作峰会。
Oh, okay, okay. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I remember while editing, I realized that I was saying that, oh, I'll get your, I'll find the link to your first talk, but there was no recording of it. But I did go and find the first recorded talk that Bryce ever gave, which was at BoostCon 2011. So even before the snowball fight of Hangzhou 2012. And it's really poor slide deck quality. Like the recording is here. let's just take a let's take a brief oh no please oh please you can barely make out and is this the highest yeah but it's
哦，好吧，好吧。是的，是的，是的。我记得在剪辑时，我意识到我在说，哦，我会去拿你的，我会找到你的第一次演讲的链接，但没有它的录音。但我确实去找到了布莱斯发表过的第一个有录音的演讲，那是在 2011 年的 BoostCon。甚至比 2012 年杭州打雪仗还要早。而且幻灯片质量真的很差。录音就在这里。让我们稍微，让我们稍微，哦不，求你了，哦求你了，你几乎看不清，这是最高级的，是的，但是是
the highest is 480p which we're on that's that's how we recorded it back then and uh cute little bryce um 10 years ago bryce the slides were actually like not terrible slides though. So yeah, like it. I did stay up until like 4 a.m. Like I was up at 4 a.m. the night before like preparing the talk and rehearsing the talk. I got like no sleep. Yeah, but so I actually, I haven't fully watched it. But what I did want is I wanted the user to actually enjoy the full talk experience.
最高是 480p，我们当时就是这么录的，然后呢，可爱的布莱斯，10 年前的布莱斯，幻灯片其实，也不是很糟糕的幻灯片。所以，是的，就像这样。我确实熬夜到凌晨 4 点。就像我前天晚上 4 点还在准备演讲和排练演讲。我几乎没睡觉。是的，但是所以其实，我还没有完全看完它。但我真正想要的是，我希望用户能够真正享受完整的演讲体验。
So I went and dug up the actual slide deck PDF, and so I linked both. I linked both the talk and then the slides, which I think is the PDF. Let's look. How many slides were in that deck? Let's take a guess. Over, under. I only used like half of my time. And I think maybe I had between 20 and 30 slides.
所以我去翻出了实际的幻灯片 PDF，所以我两个都放了链接。我把演讲和幻灯片都放了链接，我认为那是 PDF。我们来看看。那个幻灯片里有多少张幻灯片？我们来猜一下。超额，未达。我只用了大约一半的时间。我想我可能有 20 到 30 张幻灯片。
Really? Oh, I like my first boost or C++ Now talk had like 180. Yes, but Connor, you gave your first talk at like a different point in your career. I was like a little 19-year-old shit. Oh, wow. There's more. Okay. There's like 57.
真的吗？哦，我第一次在 boost 或 C++ Now 上的演讲大概有 180 张。是的，但康纳，你在职业生涯的不同阶段做了你的第一次演讲。我当时就像一个 19 岁的小混蛋。哦，哇。还有更多。好吧。大概有 57 张。
51. Okay. There's like 57, 51, 52, Bryce Lelbeck, github.com slash Bryce Lelbeck slash Prana. Let's take a look. No, no, no.
51 张。好吧，大概有 57、51、52，Bryce Lelbeck，github.com 斜杠 Bryce Lelbeck 斜杠 Prana。让我们来看看。不，不，不。
We're not looking at like stuff that I, stuff that I started building like many, many, many, many moons ago. Nope. 23 stars. Pretty good,
我们不看那些我，那些我很久很久很久很久以前开始构建的东西。不。23 个星标。相当不错，
ma'am. All right. Oh, actually. Yeah. We had good, ma'am. All right. Oh, actually. Yeah, we had a thing. We were creating a Twitter poll. Yeah, yeah. So, well, what happened is we went to the show notes to find the original BQN. And the original is actually the first solution as I switched back to this BQN tab.
伙计。好吧。哦，实际上。是的。我们有一个事情。我们在创建一个推特投票。是的，是的。所以，嗯，发生的事情是我们去了节目笔记来找原始的 BQN。原始的实际上是第一个解决方案，当我切回这个 BQN 标签页时。
It's the first solution. And I believe, so let's delete these. So the point is, BQN is awesome. And there is a Unicode symbol called after that is the dyadic hook. And also before is also like a flipped dyadic hook. So I'll leave a link. Go listen to that ArrayC. If you care. Now we're going to create this Twitter poll. Clearly this is going to, as this never happens before, this is going to be two episodes.
它是第一个解决方案。并且我相信，所以让我们删除这些。所以重点是，BQN 太棒了。有一个名为 after 的统一码符号是双向钩。而且 before 也类似于一个翻转的双向钩。所以我留一个链接。去听那个 ArrayCast 吧。如果你关心的话。现在我们要创建这个推特投票。显然，正如这以前从未发生过的那样，这将是两集节目。
You'll hear, uh, you'll hear the 2021 retro in episode. Uh, what are we on now? 50, this is 60. So you'll hear the 2021 retro in episode 61.
你会听到，呃，你会听到 2021 年回顾在节目中。呃，我们现在到第几期了？50，这是 60。所以你会听到 2021 年回顾在第 61 期。
Um, currently we're building this. So the three train, I believe is here and then the B1 combinator is here. So this is going to give one to, and so there's, what, what, what parenthesized version would you like? My version will be the five Unicode symbols. You want this version? Yeah. Okay. So this is. Let's take it to the Twitter. This is Bryce's. What do we want to call it?
嗯，目前我们正在构建这个。所以三连星，我相信在这里，然后 B1 组合子在这里。所以这将给出 1 到，所以这里有，什么，什么带括号的版本，你想要哪个版本？我的版本将是这五个统一码符号。你想要这个版本吗？是的。好的。所以这是。把它发到推特上。这是布莱斯的。我们想叫它什么？
We'll call it Bryce's. And then I'll delete all the parentheses. And we'll call this Connor's. And first we're going to go. Who do you think is going to win? I honestly. I think that it's I mean, the question is
我们叫它布莱斯的。然后我将删除所有的括号。我们叫这个康纳的。首先我们要去。你认为谁会赢？老实说。我认为这是，我的意思是，问题是
what are people going to vote based on? Are they going to vote based on the comment with a name next to it? Is it who's your favorite host? Or is it actually going to be based on the content of the poll? Wait, if it's who's your favorite host, who's going to win? Oh, I think that's me for sure.
人们会根据什么来投票？他们会根据旁边带名字的评论来投票吗？是“谁是你最喜欢的 Gastgeber（主持人）”吗？还是它实际上会根据投票的内容来投票？等等，如果是谁是你最喜欢的 Gastgeber，谁会赢？哦，我觉得那绝对是我。
I think that's me for sure. Oh, you're so very wrong about that. So very wrong about that. I have a very loyal following. Oh, man. We should do multiple polls here. We'll do a BQ. Here we go. That's very nice.
我觉得那绝对是我。哦，你在这方面大错特错了。大错特错了。我有一批非常忠实的拥趸。哦，天哪。我们应该在这里进行多次投票。我们要做一个 BQ。我们走吧。那太好了。
Alright, so now we're going to do a little screen capture. Oh, actually, we'll just copy the text into the poll as well. Alright, now we're going to Twitter. Am I actually logged in
好的，现在我们要做一个小的屏幕捕获。哦，实际上，我们也可以把文字复制到投票中。好的，现在我们要去推特。我真的登录了
to... Yeah, you're logged in. Do I actually logged in to... Yeah, you're logged in. But do I have access to ADSP from here? I don't. I think I have to go to Firefox. Why? Because I have like seven Twitter accounts and you can only log in to five at any one time
到……是的，你登录了。我真的登录到……是的，你登录了。但我从这里有权限访问 ADSP 吗？没有。我想我必须去火狐浏览器。为什么？因为我有大约七个推特账户，你任何时候只能登录五个
on a single. So get rid of some Twitter accounts. You don't get seven Twitter accounts. I'm sure JF also has this problem. I'm going to reshare just because I don't want Bryce to be left out on this experience of, or yeah, I guess I can just share my entire screen. I don't know. Then I might see stuff.
在单个浏览器上。那就删掉一些推特账户。你不需要七个推特账户。我确信 JF 也有这个问题。我将重新分享，只是因为我不想让布莱斯错过这种体验，或者，是的，我想我可以直接分享我的整个屏幕。我不知道。那样我可能会看到一些东西。
That's true it's a risk hang on I'm looking for I'm looking for anything juicy there's nothing juicy alright so here is the photo
那倒也是，有风险。等等，我在找，我在找有没有什么劲爆的东西，没有什么劲爆的。好的，所以这是照片。
oh snap you can't post photos alongside a poll alongside a poll absolute garbage well we will post that photo in a sec
哦，天哪，你不能在投票旁边发布照片，绝对是垃圾。好吧，我们待会儿会在照片中发布那个投票。
you can retweet the poll with the photo, I think. I'll just comment on it. And now we need to go back to... I guess I should get ready to retweet this with my substantially higher Twitter follower count. Yeah, yeah, yeah. That's true. That's true.
你可以用照片转发投票，我想。我只要评论一下就行了。现在我们需要回到……我想我应该准备好用我明显更高的推特粉丝数来转发这个。是的，是的，是的。没错，没错。
You do have more Twitter followers. Yeah. 10.5K. That's what I'm talking about. And let's check on how many JF has because I know he's been catching up. Yeah, I saw him troll you. Oh, no, no. Actually, JF is like a good 400 Twitter followers behind me.
你的推特粉丝确实更多。是的。10.5K。这就是我所说的。让我们看看 JF 有多少，因为我知道他一直在追赶。是的，我看到他恶搞你了。哦，不，不。实际上，JF 比我落后了大约 400 个推特粉丝。
Like he, that is the largest gap that we've had in a while. Woo! That's nice. That's nice. That's nice. Yeah, JF, you're just falling behind. Just falling behind. See, I think the problem is it's the new JF Twitter profile picture, which makes him look like he's got a very substantial beard,
就像他，那是我们一段时间以来最大的差距。呜呼！那太好了。那太好了。那太好了。是的，JF，你只是落后了。只是落后了。看，我认为问题在于 JF 的新推特头像，这让他看起来像留着非常茂密的胡子，
and it sort of makes him makes him look like jack dorsey it's not as good as his previous profile picture in my humble opinion sorry jf if you're listening to this should we leave the target indices part out? Yeah, that's what I was thinking, to emphasize more. Yeah, I think so. And I say that mostly because it is an amusing fact of languages like BQN and APL that literally the name of the function that we're defining is more characters than the function itself.
这有点让他看起来像杰克·多西（Jack Dorsey）。恕我直言，它没有他之前的头像好。抱歉，JF，如果你在听这个的话。我们应该把目标索引那部分剪掉吗？是的，我也是这么想的，以更加强调。是的，我也这么觉得。我这么说主要是因为 BQN 和 APL 语言的一个有趣事实是，字面意思是我们定义的函数的名称比函数本身的字符还要多。
And that is the beauty. The name of the function might be twice as many characters as the function definition itself. That's the beautiful thing. Like whenever you're competing in leet code, they always give their function names to the problem, like something very similar to the name of the problem, which can be, you know, four or five words. So half the time, it's like a six-character solution. And then to spell out
这就是美妙之处。函数的名称可能是函数定义本身字符的两倍。这就是美妙之处。每当你参加 LeetCode 竞赛时，他们总是给他们的函数起与问题名称非常相似的名字，这可能是，你知道的，四五个单词。所以有一半时间，它就像是一个六个字符的解决方案。然后拼写出
the name of the function, it's like 20 characters, which is the best. So what is the preferred BQN solution to target indices, parentheses from episode 56? See comment in the photo below. We'll do this for what? We'll do it for the weekend. So three days? Sure, sure. Or actually wait. Oh yeah, this is going to go out. And also too, yes, so I actually haven't put our names. No, no, no, we're not putting our names.
函数的名称，大概有 20 个字符，这才是最棒的。所以对于目标索引，来自第 56 期的带括号的 BQN 解决方案，首选是什么？见下方照片中的评论。我们什么时候做这个？我们在周末做吧？三天？当然，当然。或者其实等等。哦，是的，这个要发布了。而且，是的，实际上我还没有放我们的名字。不，不，不，我们不放名字。
We're not putting our names. Yes, of course. We will at a later date, maybe when the 2021 retro goes out, although this is going to be in episode 50, so maybe next Friday when the episode drops, we'll do a Who's Your Favorite Host? And then that's going to be in episode 50 so maybe next uh friday when the episode drops we'll do a who's your favorite host and then that's going to be pretty contentious although should we allow retweets because i feel like just we'll figure it out folks we'll figure it out
我们不放名字。是的，当然。我们会在稍后放，也许当 2021 年回顾发布时，尽管这将是在第 50 期，所以也许下周五节目上线时，我们会做一个“谁是你最喜欢的 Gastgeber”？然后那将是在第 50 期，所以也许下周，呃，周五节目上线时，我们会做一个“谁是你最喜欢的 Gastgeber”，然后那将是相当有争议的，尽管我们应该允许转发吗？因为我觉得，我们会弄明白的，伙计们，我们会弄明白的。
we're gonna we're gonna do retweets we're gonna do retweets because we need the reach all right all right i feel like half of your followers might vote against you anyways um just i mean look look look knowing knowing my um my brash and over-the-top personality it is it is quite common for even even my devoted followers to troll me incessantly as evidenced i don't know if you saw jf's little prank that he pulled on me. I did. I did. Very nice. Well done, JF. I know you all have a rival podcast. What JF did was JF sent me a link that appeared to be a link to a Wikipedia article about me,
我们要，我们要进行转发，我们要进行转发，因为我们需要覆盖面。好吧，好吧，我觉得你的半数粉丝无论如何都可能会投反对票，嗯，只是，我的意思是，看，看，看，了解，了解我的，嗯，鲁莽和夸张的个性，即使是，甚至我忠实的追随者也经常无休止地恶搞我，正如证明的那样，我不知道你是否看到了 JF 对我搞的小恶作剧。我看过。我看过。非常不错。干得好，JF。我知道你们都有一个竞争的播客。JF 做的事是，JF 发给我一个链接，看起来像是一个关于我的维基百科文章的链接，
but was actually a subtly constructed link to something else. And, yeah, he got me. He got me. got me i'm not gonna lie he got me okie dokes um 50 50 right now folks you're listening to this probably on january yesterday by the time you're listening to this episode it's too late like it's over yeah the the results of this poll have come in, and I have clearly been victorious. Connor has lost and has agreed to put parentheses in reasonable places in his BQN code. Oh, I'm not going to – what did I say last time is that the listener is misinformed if they get this poll wrong. But I honestly – I've got hopes for myself here. I think that your hopes are mis-
但实际上是一个巧妙构建的指向其他东西的链接。而且，是的，他整到我了。他整到我了。整到我了，我不会撒谎，他整到我了。好的，各位，现在是 50 对 50。当你们听到这一集时，大概是在 1 月昨天，当你们听到这一集时，已经太晚了，就像它已经结束了。是的，这个投票的结果已经出来了，我显然获胜了。康纳输了，并同意在他的 BQN 代码中合理的地方加上括号。哦，我不会——我上次说什么来着，如果听众在这个投票上搞错了，那是他们被误导了。但我老实说——我在这里对自己抱有希望。我認為你的希望被误导了——
Whoa, wait, wait, wait. You have to delete the poll. Why? I'm going to let you read the poll again and figure out why you need to delete the poll. I don't know. Look at the two options and tell me whether those are valid code. Oh, fuck. Ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha, ha.
哇，等等，等等，等等。你必须删除这个投票。为什么？我让你再读一遍投票，然后弄清楚为什么你需要删除这个投票。我不知道。看看这两个选项，告诉我这些是不是合法的代码。哦，操。哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈。
Oh, my God. Do I really? Yes, you do. It's wrong. Connor forgot a parentheses and you were like copy pasting so that shouldn't have even been a possible problem all right we're gonna do this in less than 60 seconds here we go really okay i'm timing you okay time me can connor do it can connor actually do all of the necessary retweeting in should we should we let's let's let it last for seven days then it's you it's your call that you promised to finish
哦，天哪。我真的需要吗？是的，你必须。它是错的。康纳漏掉了一个括号，你当时在复制粘贴，所以这甚至不应该是一个可能的问题。好吧，我们在不到 60 秒内搞定这个，开始吧。真的，好吧，我在给你计时。好吧，计时。康纳能做到吗？康纳真的能在——我们应该，我们让它持续七天吧，然后——这是你，你承诺要完成
this within 60 seconds and right now you're just using some of that time you are I'm done over the time I'm done I was done three seconds ago you it doesn't matter because I started recording like five seconds in. You took more than 60 seconds. You're done. You're out of here. All right. Let me go delete the old one now.
这个在 60 秒内，而你现在只是在浪费一些时间。你确实在浪费。我完成了，超时了。我完成了。我三秒钟前就完成了。你，这没关系，因为我大概在五秒钟时才开始录音。你用了不止 60 秒。你完了。你被淘汰了。好吧。让我去把旧的删掉。
Yeah. Yeah. Oh, you didn't even delete the old one already? It doesn't count if you haven't deleted the old one. And let's just check. There are the right number of parentheses. Am I allowed to vote? I don't know. I can't vote, no. You have to vote i don't know i can't vote no
是的。是的。哦，你甚至还没把旧的删掉？如果你还没删掉旧的，就不算数。我们检查一下。括号的数量对吗？我有资格投票吗？我不知道。我不能投票，不。你必须投票，我不知道。我不能投票，不。
from your actual account not that like what is this episode gonna be called bryson connor hughes twitter i was that's garbage so there was four votes before and we were tied and at one point i was ahead by a little bit and now now I'm losing. Yeah, yeah, yeah. There are no recounts in this election. Okay, so seeing as we haven't gotten to the retro yet, let's look at a couple of my other notes, and my notes say that we should announce NVIDIA's GTC conference has gone virtual, thanks to Omicron.
从你真正的账户，不是像——这一集叫什么名字？布莱斯和康纳·休斯的推特。太垃圾了。所以之前有四票，我们打平了，有一段时间我稍微领先了一点，现在——现在我落后了。是的，是的，是的。这次选举没有重新计票。好吧，既然我们还没到回顾部分，让我们看看我的其他一些笔记，我的笔记说我们应该宣布英伟达的 GTC 会议由于奥密克戎（Omicron）而已转为虚拟会议。
Are we? Is that a thing that's public yet? All right. We won't be announcing that. Actually, let's check. I'm going to check. I'm going to check whether that's public. But in the interest of us.
我们是吗？那是已经公开的事情吗？好吧。我们不会宣布那个。事实上，我们检查一下。我要检查一下。我要检查一下那是否公开。但在为了我们……
I know the speakers were informed. I suspect the speakers were informed. FAQ. What is GTC? GTC will be an online event. Woo! Okay, alright, alright. I guess we can say it. I guess we can say it.
我知道演讲者得到了通知。我怀疑演讲者得到了通知。常见问题解答。什么是 GTC？GTC 将是一个在线活动。呜呼！好吧，好吧，好吧。我想我们可以说。我想我们可以说。
So yeah, that's sad. I was really looking forward. That might have been the first time we had seen each other in over two years at that point. Well, we live like a short distance away you should just come visit me uh ontario's back in lockdown all non-essential travel is not encouraged so you had in the spring in the spring you can come crash on this glorious couch and gtc was going to be in the spring anyways the call for papers for cpp north will be opening on uh january 24th which
所以，是的，这很令人难过。我真的很期待。到那个时候，那可能是我们两年多来第一次见到彼此。好吧，我们住得很近，你应该来找我玩。呃，安大略省又开始封锁了，所有非必要的出行都不鼓励，所以你可以在春天，在春天你可以来我这张光荣的沙发上借宿，而且 GTC 本来也就是在春天举行。无论如何，C++ North 的论文征集将于 1 月 24 日开始，
i believe is a monday um so get your talk proposals ready for a hopefully in-person conference in toronto canada the first ever c++ canadian uh conference um hopefully that it is still planning to go on but you know obviously we will monitor what's going on we will see and yeah i think that's where we'll wrap out wrap up episode 60 thanks for listening we hope you enjoyed and have a great day There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我相信那是一个星期一，所以准备好你的演讲提案吧，有望在加拿大多伦多举办一场线下会议，这是史无前例的加拿大 C++ 会议，希望它仍然计划举行，但你知道，显然我们会密切关注情况，我们会拭目以待，是的，我想这就是我们结束第 60 期节目的地方。感谢收听，我们希望你喜欢，祝你拥有美好的一天。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。